[Music]
polythen 2 is an automatic tool for
prediction of the possible impact of an
amino acid substitution on the structure
and function of a human protein
automated predictions of this kind are
essential for interpreting large data
sets of rare genetic variants
which have many applications in modern
human genetics research
uses in recent research include
identifying rare alleles that cause
mendelian disease
scanning for potentially medically
actionable alleles in an individual's
genome
and profiling the spectrum of rare
variation uncovered by deep sequencing
of large populations
polyphen predicts functional effects of
amino acid variations
based on both multi-sequence alignment
and protein 3d structure features
it is based on three presumptions the
first is the same as in sift
that amino acid variations at conserved
positions are more likely to cause
functional changes
the second presumption is that amino
acid variations that affect the active
sites
interaction sites solubility or
stability of a protein
are likely to affect protein structure
the third presumption is that changes in
protein structure are likely to cause
changes in protein function
which are likely to cause changes in
phenotype
polyphen 2 uses eight sequence based and
three structure based predictive
features which were selected
automatically by an
iterative greedy algorithm majority of
these features involve comparison of a
property of the wild-type allele
and the corresponding property of the
mutant allele which together define an
amino acid replacement
most informative features characterize
how well the two human alleles fit into
the pattern of amino acid replacements
within the multiple sequence alignment
of homologous proteins
how distant the protein harboring the
first deviation from the human wild-type
allele is from the human protein
and whether the mutant allele originated
at a hypermutable site
the alignment pipeline selects the set
of homologous sequences for the analysis
using a clustering algorithm and then
constructs and refines their multiple
alignment
the functional significance of an allele
replacement is predicted from its
individual features by naive bayes
classifier
in this example we will investigate the
effects of p53
our 273 h mutation in the protein
or snp identifier text box enter a
protein identifier
polythene 2 uses the uniprot kb database
as a reference source for all protein
sequences
and annotations you can also enter human
protein
identifiers from other databases such as
refsec or standard gene symbols
however uniprot kb identifiers are
preferred as the most reliable and
unambiguous
leave the protein sequence in fasta
format text box
empty enter the position of the
substitution in the protein sequence
into the position text box
for this example type 273
select the appropriate boxes for the
wild type amino acid residue aa1
and the substitution residue aa2
for this example select our 4aa1 and
h4a2
respectively enter an optional
description into the query description
text box
click the submit query button you will
be transferred to the grid gateway
interface web page
use the refresh button to reload the
page until your query job is listed
under completed click the corresponding
view link to browse the polyfen 2
prediction report for your query
you will be presented with the web page
listing your query and the prediction
and confidence panel prediction outcome
can be one of probably damaging
possibly damaging or benign score is the
probability of the substitution being
damaging
sensitivity and specificity correspond
to prediction confidence
the predicted damaging effect is also
indicated by a vertical black marker
inside a color gradient bar
where green is benign and red is
damaging
by default only the prediction based on
the hum div model is shown
click on the plus control box next to
the humvar label to display the humbar
based prediction
and scores click on the plus control box
next to multiple sequence alignment to
display the multiple sequence alignment
panel
this panel displays a multiple sequence
alignment for 75 amino acid residues
surrounding your variance position in
the query sequence
click the link at the bottom of the
panel to open an interactive alignment
viewer to scroll through the complete
alignment
click on the plus control box next to 3d
visualization to display the interactive
3d protein structure viewer applet